there was a question last night as the
coach has left the field following Bill
O'Brien's first ever victory over Bill
Belichick O'Brien had spent time in New
England he had been Owen five against
Belichick did you saw it yeah what what
did you make of the everything with Bill
Belichick is awkward yes right or
another what did you make of that
interaction yeah I mean bill is never
really warm and cozy with anybody Bill
Belichick that is after games but that
seemed to be more abrupt than normal it
was literally like a walk across your
body I shook your hand so we could say
we could do it but I'm not really gonna
break my stride of walking to where yeah
I looked at it as like oh I think he's
still a little bitter about the
offseason stuff to me that looked like
he felt like old friends went behind his
back and schemed something up without
telling him and he's probably like I've
done a lot of good for you guys that
have you know tried to you know push you
in the right direction and shed some
knowledge on you and then here you guys
go behind my back talking about the
effort the hard way Nick Sarah exactly
that to me was probably what would
showed to me the fact that the Patriots
filed tampering charges suggest that
there is some venom there there's some
hostility some hard feelings you know
the belief was that that Jack Easter bee
who had been an executive with the
Patriots shows up at the ring ceremony
at Robert Kraft's house spotted talking
extensively with Nick Caesarea and it's
the next day that the Texans fired Brian
gain and immediately requested
permission to interview Nick Kesari oh
so they were they were skeptical about
it from the get-go it got ugly quickly
and the Texans backed off but but but
you're right there's a right way to do
things as a wrong way to do things and
look at where the Texans are they didn't
get Kesari oh they may never get
Caesarea they're talking about not
having a GM for next year although I'll
believe that when I see it but it could
be that there's a little something there
and yeah the bottom line is
belcheck got his butt whooped for the
second time this year on a Sunday night
and you just have to wonder how many
more of those are coming right III you
know I don't know if a lot of coming as
far as getting there but what but that's
a scary matchup for them nonetheless and
the playoffs
if the Sean Watson and company come into
town and the Texans defense does look
like it's turning the cool
a little bit there especially with some
of these new you know people they've
acquired and through you know Vernon
Hargreaves Gary and Connelly you know
Reed getting back healthy maybe they can
bolster that defense a little bit to
where their format a little because
that's been a big issue but man if
Watson comes to town and has to go up to
New England that will not be you know an
easy matchup for the New England
Patriots at any point Chiefs at the
Bengals bills and dolphins three of
their final four games are at home yeah
I mean the Patriots should be able to
get a bye yes they may have squandered
their their shot at the top seed but you
know you talk about the Shaun Watson you
look at what he did to the Patriots we
saw what Lamar Jackson did we've seen
historically what mobile quarterbacks
right one of the it makes me convinced
that the Patriots next quarterback is
gonna be mobile I wouldn't be shocked
that if they went that way and the you
know they're the type of coaching staff
that has proven to us that they're ahead
of the times more times than not whether
inventing new offensive philosophies
even what they're doing on defense
they're behind times now well yeah they
are but they've gotten you know okay
they're behind the times and what was
the price of being behind the times
winning six Super Bowls and going to
nine of life I don't disagree with that
my point is we the trend is already lost
yeah and they're catching up to
everybody else right you get a mobile
quarterback yeah no yes it is but I
still think New England would be more
the type to know how to utilize it but I
think they really like Jared said them
too and I don't know if they're gonna
you know change a whole lot of of what
their approach is as far as Belichick
offensive football what he learned with
the Giants and and all of that I still
think they're gonna be somewhat what we
see right now but they just need more
weapons on offense in general
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports